Sylvain Desjardins a rencontré
des artistes qui ont
héritage.
- Est-ce qu'il est vrai que
vous avez l'intention de lâcher
le Pusususususususususususususuz
rajeuni la formule, mais si vous
questions comme ça...
(rires)
le côté "bum, le côté grandiose,
le côté poète...
- J'ai jamais pensé...
que je pouvais être aussi fier
d'être québécois que ce soir.
- Je pense que René Lévesque est
un héros, une personne simple
du peuple, courageuse,
qui a un code d'éthique.
(cris de la foule)s s s s s s ss
au monde pour qu'on... un peuple
complet ait ene e de le suivre.
- Il leur appartiendra...
- La détermination de René
Lévesqprprprprprprprprprprprprp.
- 16 ans...
Y Y compris ceux de nombreux
jeunes qui n'avaient pas encore
l'âge de voter pour lui.
- J'avais 12 ans que j'étais
comme... j'étais "scotché"
à ma télévision. Je l'avais vu
faire son "on n'est pas
peuple, on est peut-être
quelque chose coe e un..."
- On n'est pas un petit peuple.
On est p
comme un grand peuple.
J'J'avais eu des frissons.
J'avais le poil qui me dressait
Je découvrais c'était quoi
et le Québec et la frtrté
d'être québécois.
- 1.24 sur 1 première...
Emmanuel Bilodeau réalise
son plus gndnd rêve : celui
d'incarner son héros d'enfance
dans une série télévisée.
son sens aigu de la nuance. Il a
jama p pris les Québécois pour
des imbéciles. Il parlait franc,
il parlait vrai, mais il parlai.
Il a jamais essayé de réduire
au plus simple dénominateur
commun parce que "ah, le public
comprendra pas!" Non, lui,fifif.
Oh, my God!
- Avant de devenir acteur,
le jeune Bilodeau a d'abord
été journalist t t t t t t t t l
"La Presse", il a eu l'occasion
de rencontrer René Lévesque
pour une longue interview,
quel
Un moment marquant.
- Ah regarde ça! C'est ça, là.
- C'est ça, c'est votre
article, ça?
- Ça, c'est un de mes articles.
Comme s'il était en entrevue
Bernard Derome, là!
Il était fin, il était éloquent,
il était motivé, il répondaiton.
Je capotais.
Ça fait que j'ai
l'enregistrement analogue,
que j'ai mis sur le téléphonntne
avec René Lévesque.
- Chacun son opinion, mais faire
l'indépendance... Quand t'es
une province dans un pays,
il faut tout de mê'a'a'a'a'a'a'n
et que ce soit clair.
- Je me suis servi beaucoup
de cet enregistrement-là après .
- M. Lévesque, M. Lévesque,
les jeunes ne vous suivent plus.
- Ça, j'en suis pas si
Toute façon, c'est pas
une raison pour me poiararder
en public.
Je me souvenais de
de chaque inflexion de voix,
de regard
Bien, venez la chercher, sur le
plancher du co
- Et le Gémeaux est remis à...
- Ce travail'a'acteur minutieux
a d'ailleurs valu un prix
Gémeaux
en 2007.
- L'inpependance du Québec,
c'était comme un rêve.
Re
politique de rêve. Le jouer,
esest un... c'est un rêve aussi.
Ça a été un rêve. De gagner ça,
Il était pas intéressé par
autre chose que par le bien
commun puis le... l'avancement
Regarde ça que c'est que
je trouve. J'ai gardé ça, moi.
- Ah oui!
était mort.
- ♪ Et je te dis, René,
à la prochaine fois ♪
- Un collectif de bédéistes
regroupés autour de l'auteur
revivre les moments forts
de la vie de René Lévesque.
Certains épisodes connus
MARC TESSIER, scénariste
et réalisateur de bande dessinée
- René Lévesque, c'était
quelqu'un de courageux.
Dans toutes mes vevevevevevevevt
que la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
pour lui, c'était la grande
aventure de son siècle. Alors,
c'était la grande aventure.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La première BD nous présente
René Lévesque, à 22 agagagagagan
pour l'armée américaine,
un jeune homme téméraire,
confronté à la peur de mourir.ft
Québécois qui s'en va à
l'extérieur du pays, qui apprend
tout ça, qui nous représente,
pu
toute cette expérience-là,
puis qui travaille à ouvr,r, à
défoncer les portes. Il y avait
quelque chose dans René Lévesque
Il avait pas un styliste
ou quelqu'un pour le "prompter",
tout lui expliquer,
dire ça. Ça va accrocher."
C'est une bande dessinée
qui raconte...
de petites histoires élégamment
insérées dans la grande.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans
nationalisation, il y a une page
où que Jean Lesage p pris
un petit coup de trop et il est
un petit peu agressif vis-à-visé
Lévesque voit qu'il est soûl,
on va... Il engage pas
dans sa colère.
(cris de la foule)
Tt t le cheminement de René
Lévesque, il y a eu des hauts et
des bas, puis
qu'il allait gagner l'élection.
Alors, je trouvais que c'éta
une célébration, une explosion.
C'était comme des feux o o o o t
de la couleur, c'est une bonne
idée. Alors, ça venait
du dessinateur. C'était un...
♪ ♪ ♪
Il  avait une certaine dignité,
René Lévesque. Il y a quelqueeun
approche. Quand qui gagne, puis
qu'il... qu'il se rend compte
qu'il a la responsabilité
moi, ça... ça vient me chercher.
- C'est tellement vite
- Quand il apprend qu'il est
élu, la pression lui tombe
dessus, puis son premier
réflexe, c'est pas d'aller
fêter,'e'est de faire :
"Oh, mon Dieu, qu'est-ce quecccc
toutes ces responsabilités?"
- (foule): René! René! René!
- 35 ans après sa rencontre avec
vie à la télévision, Emmanuel
Biloauau est encore imprégné
de la forte personnalité
de René Lévesque.
où il a choisi d'emprunter
sa voix et ses mimiques
pour conclure son plus récent
spectacle su
- Un pays et une culture
qui ne seront plus jamais
inquie
- S'il vous plaît...
- René Lévesque, bien,
il
entrepris, mais il l'a fait avec
tellement de panache, et il a
tellement de d'humilité puis
de convictio, , c'est un...
peut-être un genre d'anti-héros,
héros. En tout cas, pour d d d ,
c'est le modèle à suivre
pour faire de la politique.
- On lui doit beaucoup, tu sais,
à c
de courage qui s'est battu
pour nous autres. Il en prend
pour tout le monde sur son dos,
puis il s'en va avec ça, puis
avec ça. Puis, il a réussi.
Pour moi, c'est ça, un hér..
- Si je vous ai bien compris,
vous êtes en train de dire
(cridede la foul